اذا باحثون في جامعه باستن و فيرجينيا
والى نويت كتبوا اننا سبب في انخفاض العمر
البيولوجي ربما يعزى لاليات العمر
الاساسيه لكن ما هي خطه التجربه طلب من
السيدات تناول الخضروات وبذور اليقطين
وبذور دوار الشمس والشمندر ومكملات الكبد
والبيض بنسب معينه كما طلب منهم تناول
حصتين يوميا من مكونات الميثيل ومنها
التوت البري والثوم والشاي الاخضر والكركم
وطلب ايضا تغييرات بنمط الحياه كتناول
البروبايتك وشرب الماء والرياضه لنصف ساعه
على الاقل والتدرب على التنفس والنوم
لثماني ساعات على الاقل وصيام 12 ساعه عن
الطعام بين الوجبه والاخرى في النهايه اكد
الباحثون انه رغم عدم الالتزام الكامل من
النساء لكن شوهدت تحسينات في العمر
البيولوجي بينهم بمعدل
82% من الوقت
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات